[Musik]
die schweizer alpen noch vor 150 jahren
waren sie unberührtes territorien
bis einzelne pioniere anfingen wege auf
die gipfel zu suchen
und der schweizer alpen-club shc begann
das gebirge mit hütten zu überziehen
heute sind die einst unberührten berge
freizeitparadies für die massen
doch was trieb die pioniere von damals
an
und warum lockt es uns heute noch auf
die berge
[Musik]
es ist ende juni start in die
sommersaison auf der fremden hütte
oberhalb von kandersteg die
wiedereröffnung nach den winter ist für
den hüttenwart markierten leib kein tag
wie jeder andere
das ist eben besonders wohl ein
so waren hier los ist kaputt ging im
wind und wasser ist oder ob cash und ob
die wall street legen funktioniere vor
allem oder irgendwann entladen herbst
das dorf rohren stärker werden lassen
das ist alles neu kaum ist drinnen das
telefon in betrieb kommen die ersten
reservationen herein rostock musste ein
buch blätter so wichtig der zweite sehr
gerne mit nacht und morgen das aber
braucht schon habe ich noch nicht wo
für erwachsene ist es auch das 60
[Musik]
market heute nur einen einzigen
zahlenden gast haben einen touristen aus
kandersteg hütten wanderer sind die am
stärksten wachsende es ac n t
und sie kommen auch bei schlechtem
wetter ich hatte eine e mail geschickt
auch mit knochen steckt heute glauben
nicht dass nach dessen später war sie
dann kommt noch der vorstand hoch ja
gerne brauchen sie eine anmeldung oder
so von mir oder erlaubt die vier monate
für die hütten gibt julia es gibt immer
wieder der in zwei wochen also der
stoffe und er muss man auch damit sich
sein aber sie und die zieht halt
irgendwie auf einer klassenreise
einschlafen und teilt mit töre hier im
händler schlafraum heimat platz für 24
personen und dann wird es kuschelig warm
das ist eine klassische ec es ist nur
ganz klassisches erzählt verstehen was
der vorgang macht ist zu achten dass man
die komfortable hätte unterzeichnen muss
schlafen was zur folge hat dass man
jetzt halte ich wenig geschlafen platz
fürchten und schlafplatz kreuz immer
noch auf 60
die truppen hätten watt muss anpacken
können mag installiert mit einem
kollegen die wasserpumpe sie versorgt
die hütte mit schmelzwasser mag ist 36
jahre alt und arbeitet im winter wenn
die hütte geschlossen ist als
hochleistungs monteur im tal dieser
gleichgewichts sorgt die freundin hütte
liegt hoch über dem erschienen sie auf
2500 meter in den bergen genügend wasser
zu finden wird für immer mehr sap hütten
zum problem
auch hier musste die wasserfassung schon
zwei mal verlegt werden
bis jetzt jeden tag nur wasser kommt
aber diesmal drei wochen am stück hören
sie richtig schon das nächste mal
zunächst und das schweigen ist zumindest
bislang
das funktioniert das maximale was der
schlussakt einer guten ruf genoss
mark hat in seiner hütte schon viele
gäste er lebt auf einen besuch ist er
besonders stolz
er war noch hätten junge als die gesamte
schweizer regierung im jahr 2000 auf der
fremden hügel zu besuch war
programmiertes ökologisch
landesregierung software ag damalige
bundesratspräsident die stars einer
kollegin berger klar die heimische könnt
ihr natürlich der sektion hotels und der
sektion konnte hier die hütte
hintergrund sieht es denn mit seinen
bundesratskollegen schon einmal unser
land
am abend ist der vereinsvorstand des ac
alters von kandersteg hochgekommen
erhält einmal pro jahr
hier oben sitzung an
die man daraus ziehen damit die
solaranlage stock ist aber auch das ist
jetzt größer je mehr kapazität 110
sektion wie diese gibt es in der ganzen
schweiz
ihnen gehören die fac hütten und sie
kommen für den unterhalt auf der
vorstand ist zufrieden mit mark als
hüttenwart er ist der einzige der nicht
ehrenamtlich arbeitet was die gäste fürs
essen berappen fließt in seine tasche
der übernachtungs anteil geht an die
sektion doch reich wird man als
hüttenwart selten
es gibt ja verschiedene interesse und da
gibt es die hier ganz still und
geschäftlicher hier weitermache
zur not das ist heute sap hütten wie
diese in den schweizer bergen gibt hat
eine lange vorgeschichte
[Musik]
bevor der sap gegründet wurde waren die
schweizer berge noch unberührt
es waren die eroberungs lustigen
engländer die sich ab 1830 als erste auf
die berggipfel wagten mitglieder des
englischen alpenclubs bezwangen einen
viertausender nach dem anderen
dass ausländer als erster auf den
schweizer bergen standen wollte er
ändern
der berner geologie professor rudolf
theodor sind
[Musik]
es ist das jahr 1862 simmler ist mit
klarer führen auf dem weg zum tor die
als er die idee zur gründung eines
schweizer alpenclubs hat
[Musik]
ein zusammenschluss von schweizer
bergfreunden um die vielen noch
unbekannten gipfel zu erkunden
[Musik]
1863 wird in olten der src gegründet das
protokoll unterzeichnet von rudolf
theodor sinn
[Musik]
die geschichte des schweizer alpenclubs
ist hier eingelagert in der bürger
bibliothek in bergen der historiker
daniel anker hat sich seit seiner
studienzeit den bergen verschrieben
in seiner chronik zum 150 jahre jubiläum
des ac hat er erstmals alle gründer
näher vorgestellt
auch rudolf simmler der aus
patriotischen gefühlen heraus zur
gründung eines helvetischen alpenclubs
aufrief es löste dies geht es der zimmer
irgend jetzt für höchste haupt
einklappen und gründet sich auf 750
england erst bestätige machen ist witzig
siehst dass sie nachher otto überschrieb
sie sind nur einfach das material stetig
macht sondern mit orange business
services für ein star und wie man
aufgrund einer proton hund einfach auf
die banken dass man plötzlich nur noch
als schiedsrichter hätte
es waren 35 männer alle aus der
deutschschweiz die 1863 den fac
gründeten die meisten akademiker und
beamte ihre idee hat auswirkungen bis
heute
sicher die wichtigste rolle spielt dann
kann man auch schon mal das seehotel
haare täglich das gebirge schweiz
überhaupt beschlossen die großen
bekannten berger sicher schon
miteinander sie zum teil mit technische
fehler aber nach genau die ringenberger
wie die hellwach und was mir gesagt
wurde dass die chance eigentlich drei
sätze
die menschen die bergwelt näher bringen
das ist heute noch vereins ziel des fc
auf der fremden hütte ist noch marcel
winter eingekehrt
trotzdem ist hüttenwerk tag der vorstand
des sc altes stellt den steilen
wanderweg vom erschienen sie zu freunden
hütte hinauf entstand nach dem winter
müssen geländer neu verlegt und große
steine beseitigt werden
es braucht enthusiasmus um mit
anzupacken
dieser mann ist ein es hat sie alles und
gleichzeitig auch geschäftsführer des
gesamtschweizerischen essebsi
das machen wir dann rechts geldströme
und die ganzen mitglied und das schon
wichtig dass man dafür freiwillige
helfer des geschäfts stellt bayern und
die ganz große sektion heiß zwei
personen nach stellt der browser
basierte für ehrenamtlichkeit sein
normaler arbeitsplatz
der sitz des verbandes in bern der sc
ist heute praktisch ein unternehmen ihr
und filz managt die geschäfte des
sportverbandes der heute über 140.000
mitglieder hat an dieser sitzung geht es
um personal team um das arbeiten von zu
hause aus januar ist das jetzt das
schwere wort wir wollen an die
mitarbeiter grundsätzlich gleich
behandeln wenn wir dann sagen in diesem
bereich ist das möglich und hier geht
das nicht da spannungen im stehen oder
dass das müssen wir uns schon gut
überlegen
und ich würde auch sagen ersatz bieten
wir und die chance von teilzeitarbeit es
gibt sehr viele mitarbeiter die teilzeit
arbeitet also die aspekte die die markus
einbringt die sind die sind legitim
ihres budgets zweistelligen
millionenbudget home er ja aber auch
umsetzen
der club ist extrem gewachsen ist sehr
professionell aufgestellt und gerade die
kombination zwischen ehrenamtlichkeit
die sektion untergestellt bayern das
macht uns das war die geschäftsstelle
des sc vor 140 jahren das sogenannte
zentralkomitee als die esa zähler
begannen die berge zu erkunden wurde das
bergsteigen gerade erst erfunden
[Musik]
das ist ein alter film der die
erstbesteigung der jungfrau 1811
nacherzählt so hat man sich das werk
gehen im neunzehnten jahrhundert
vorzustellen
hütten gab es noch keine geschlafen
wurde im freien leitern wurden mit
getragen um gletscherspalten zu
überwinden
[Musik]
ein schwarzes tuch musste als
sonnenbrille reichen
[Musik]
die leute aus den bergen oft ganz jäger
oder bauern waren die träger und führer
die gebildeten herren und der stadt
fühlten sich als entdecker des eigenen
landes
die naturwissenschaften begannen
aufzublühen es war eine zeit in der noch
nicht klar war ob menschen auf
gletschern oder in großen höhen
überhaupt überleben mit einer gipfel
fahne wurde die besteigung besiegelt die
erstbegeher hofften dass sie auch vom
tal aus sichtbar sein würde
[Musik]
auch die gründer des ac ihnen so in die
berge etwa von schellenberg neben
simmler eine wichtige gründe figur
jetzt geht ohne diese wie sport stefan
hecker vom alpinen museum zeigt daniel
anker gegenstände die gründer andreas
braun manchmal glaube ich werde jetzt
nicht aber leiter bis 2
das ist quasi reminiszenzen als ich ihn
je arbeite ich ja nach bauingenieur
gesehen dass im inland blick und sagte
sheens ausbruch berge das minara also
morgen früher wie sich statt diese wie
sie liest ein buch das mit einer flasche
cola flasche mit wasser gemischt wie
flaschen champagner flaschen oder ganz
häufig findet uhr harry potter
abgeschnitten abgeflammt hätte die
gesteckt oder müsse aufpassen dass man
sich nicht schnitt und achim somit mit
dem flaschenhals bei omv der berühmte
berner oberland obergfell gestartete
aufgeschnitten der pause nach
es lauerten überall gefahren für die
pioniere der alpen
die ersten berg fotografen scheuten
keinen aufwand um den leuten im tal zu
zeigen wie es groben im hochgebirge
aussieht sie schleppten schwere
fotoausrüstungen in große höhen hinauf
um die bergwelt zu dokumentieren
[Musik]
der fac publizierte die bilder in seinen
büchern als orientierung für spätere
werke
[Musik]
einer der ersten berg fotografen war
lübeck seine glasplatten sammlung aus
dem neunzehnten jahrhundert lagert heute
noch im alpinen museum beck benutzte
damals ganz moderne spezielle
fotoplatten die erst im tal unten
entwickelt werden mussten
und du das hätte viele viele lichter
jungs richtig kann sie andere fotograf
akteure overhead aber längere
belichtungszeiten kann man sieht dass
die figuren wofür sind sie meistens
nicht schafft ja meistens nicht ruhig
haben immer meine berggeister wie
motorik revidiert werden fotografien
sich bewegten und denner sowie spanisch
[Musik]
schließlich machte der ehc auch die
ersten genauen landeskarten vom gebirge
exkursion scorte führt zweite exkursion
steve gebiert dem rhonegletscher der die
straße ca porsche hat die gestiegen
damals strahle stock und dazu hätte
heute braucht und die horte dreck macht
wo die fukato moderne cadisch großem
maßstab ziehen die beiden module geld
und der absatzeinbruch aber ich hatte
mir brauchen bessere karte was wir heute
mit schweiz landesvater idee gerufen
als er zurückkommt darstellt gestochen
von erneut sänger andreas ac das heißt
mitglied des ersatzes maßstab 1 zu 50
die hündin hütte in der sommersaison
eine bergsteigergruppe des ac anteils
den die hütte gehört hat den aufstieg
hinter sich gebracht
[Applaus]
die 28 jährige andrea lüthi ist touren
leiterin
sie kennt mag den hüttenwart von
gemeinsamen src touren
[Musik]
es ist hochsaison die hütte ist jetzt an
den wochenenden fast immer voll
vor allem mit bergsteigern
[Musik]
unterdessen sind auch andere gäste
angekommen
ein fußballklub aus dem thurgau wie
einen wochenendausflug macht nicht die
typische saz
[Gelächter]
am abend bespricht die s t gruppe die
geplante bergtour
es ist möglich dass man morgen begann
vom gletscher zum fels pc tastaturen
leiter wie andrea sind keine bergführer
sondern normale tourengänger die beim
skc eine ausbildung gemacht haben eine
große verantwortung
frauen in den bergen das war lange keine
selbstverständlichkeit der sc war im
männerverein und weigerte sich
bergsteigerinnen aufzunehmen darum
gründeten frauen früher einen eigenen
berg club es dauerte bis ins jahr 1978
bis der konservative sap nicht mehr
anders konnte als auch frauen
aufzunehmen
vor 115 jahren ist der sap gegründet
worden von männern für männer heute nun
rund 14 jahre nachdem die erste frau die
eigernordwand durchquert hat haben die
sht abgeordneten mit der reinen
männerbastion shc aufgeräumt es geht
hier einzig und allein um den grundsatz
wollen wir das problem frauen in
irgendeiner form lösen oder nicht
gewichtige einwände lagen auf dem tisch
die gefahr ähnlicher konflikte
dürfen die männer nicht auch unter sich
sein
[Musik]
dafür sprach unter anderem das argument
die ideen der frauen sind so gut wie
diejenigen der männer
den zeichen der zeit konnten sich
schließlich auch die saz nicht mehr
verschließen
eine große mehrheit stimmt der 1978 der
aufnahme zu in der fremden hütte ist
hüttenwart nach in schuss sein haus ist
voll belegt selbst marx 11 jährige neffe
packt mit an
auch marks freundin marica hilft mit sie
arbeitet unter der woche als
rettungssanitäterin dazu kommt jetzt im
sommer fast jedes wochenende eine hütten
schichtsystem die gäste erwarten heute
auch in den saz niedrig es spricht sich
schnell herum ob gut gekocht wird
dementsprechend haben hütten mehr oder
weniger gäste
derartige schmerzlicher vorbereitung zu
schlagen doch die art oder stock war das
stück nicht so gut 16 stunden woche
[Musik]
das bauen von hütten war von anfang an
das wichtigste ziel der sap-gründer es
ist das jahr 1936 die freundin hütte
wird gebaut
[Musik]
die steine für den bau werden vor ort
aus dem fels gesprengt
fast der ganze saz elz war auf den
beinen um anzupacken der kandersteger
lehrer rudi rust filmte wie das bauwerk
entstand es ist das wohl älteste
dokument eines hüttenbusch wochenlang
wurde bearbeitet vieles von hand hoch
geschleppt
auch soldaten halfen mit
um die zeit des zweiten weltkriegs
pflegten das militär und der patriotisch
gesinnte es ac ein enges verhältnis der
shc unterstützte die armee war der
landesverteidigung die armee half den sc
beim hüttenbau ex bundesrat adolf ogi
mit seinen cousins herrmann und fritz
sie alle sind mitglieder des faz s ihr
großvater war der erste hüttenwart der
front nötig
in den vierziger und fünfziger jahren
waren sie oft bei ihm auf dem berg
also dass ich das ist eine alte
großvater vater und mich recht ersatz
erhöhten fläche wie hüte oder mir
vielleicht trinken tee kaffee und suppe
brot das regel müssten mittragen
und das ganz anders park stieg sie als
hyper natürlich sehr viel kraft auch
super kamera die die marke würfel im
inland sowie ihre kredit besteht die
ursprung für jede super würfel hauptgang
gesetz zurück
hotelbetriebe ich unser familienbetrieb
führt zu sicher sein
so sei es in den anfängen in den sap
hütten aus gekocht wurde selber hütten
warte gab es keine
geschlafen wurde auf stroh die hütten
waren damals noch schlicht eine schutz
unterkunft auf dem weg zum gipfel
[Musik]
das ist die erste sap hütte gebaut
unterhalb des die danach kamen jedes
jahr mehrere dazu
[Musik]
die assoziierten ganz sicher heck sie
hat mir nicht dass seine spieler
natürlich mit der entwicklung von bord
die entscheiden die bürger der
urgroßvater von adolf ogi und seinen
cousins hat in cannes das stück
geschichte geschrieben
er stand mit einem engländer als erster
auf der berühmten blue me st das ist
dessen der csl richtige gemacht oder
großvater karl may das ja so legende
früheres kesse der glaube mit dem
sackmesser mit stuhr verkauft etwas ist
die bestätigung aller macht s bahnführer
buch das heißt ja früheren hier vor der
kirche auf der bank sepah für die
oberkochener glotze dass das ist richtig
sie sucht andere respekt und ananassaft
oder nachteil
eine quasi sagt auch sie
das führen gab den kandersteger eine
neue einnahmequelle
sie führten reiche touristen auf
gletscher und berge die nationalen und
internationalen gäste suchten dass sie
durch das sie in den industrialisierten
städten verloren hatten
der fac organisierte bergführer kurse
und verlieh diplom für die führe
initiierte er eine erste
unfallversicherung
[Musik]
die berge sind noch heute das kapital
von kandersteg das dorf am nordeingang
des lötschbergtunnels hat 1300 einwohner
und lebt primär vom tourismus die
bläsergruppe die ob kandersteg thront
kennt jeder tourist aber auch kann der
steaks berühmtesten einwohner über dem
erschienen sie die gipfel die ogs
urgroßvater erst bestiegen hat die berge
haben für adolf ogi eine magie sie
buhten ihn immer kraft und inspiration
in schwierigen situationen auch in der
politik 2001 gelten ja als
bundespräsident an bevor 45 minuten hält
die arbeit fünf minuten sogar und die
landschaft die natur die laut beobachter
mit nacht langsam im schlicht mit
startnummer mit leichtem wunderland
rennen
wir haben sozusagen und bücher für 2001
in viel kürzerer zeit als üblich
besprochen sie wenig sie unverzüglich
sie die bundes auf die 2001 ein
überschuss von 6,5 milliarden franken
seit seiner jugend ist adolf ogi
mitglied in sap das sind jetzt 56 jahre
[Musik]
es war anfangs 1900 als in der schweiz
der bergbahn boom einsetzte
das war die erste seilbahn sie führte
auf das wetterhorn bei kindern bald
ab 1912 brachte die jungfraubahn täglich
hunderte touristen in die vorher
unberührte gletscherlandschaft
[Musik]
selbst auf das matterhorn und dem bix
berliner waren damals bahnen geplant der
fac beobachtete den rummel in den bergen
kritisch naturschutz wurde schweizweit
zum thema auch der sc nahm den schutz
der bergwelt explizit als weiteres
verein stil auf
die berge sie nunmehr alleine für park
stich sondern immer vorsichtig werden
nach natur erste oscar des plötzlich
entdeckt worden
du dich steht die heile bergwelt die
cdu-ministerin nach und wie man den
türchen jungfraujoch meine herren
die hauptschule moskau eine sieht dass
plötzlich nick park stehen die berge
haben
aber mir die ganze zeit nicht aus dass
meine wie nachher vierte gipfel der
bahnhof geführt da ist es natürlich nur
mehr attraktiv zum beispiel so dass die
der bamboo wirklich groß ist wurde man
aktiv geschaffen das mit geschützt ist
die bank
die erhaltung der intakten bergwelt
trotz gleichzeitiger nutzung ist heute
die größte herausforderung für den sc
und den geschäftsführer ihren fies
[Musik]
die banken selber nicht klar was mich
stört ist dass der druck zunimmt dass er
viel intensität wanderer bergsteiger
zentrale thematik von der energie klinik
oder etwas aus der spur
darüber diskutierte heimat ganz verkehr
nord süd achse und das ist natürlich ein
thema wo ist dann wohl die ganze flügel
sich hier sind aber wunderschöne fleck
aber das ist ein schwieriges interviews
machen permanenten helikopter das
flugzeug in der luft ist das
ritterturnier sind unter anderen seite
natürlich hotel hamburg wird auch am
niesen wird gerade gebaut
lärm und aussichtsplattformen gehören
heute auf vielen alpengipfeln zum alltag
auch der sc selber bringt viele leute in
die berge heute trägt der alpen club für
einen stopp in der erschließung der
bergwelt ein ganz klar so dass man hört
die autoschlosser hazy nicht einig dass
mit einer nahezu es einfach selber
optimiert bestehende gelände kambodscha
touristische infrastruktur vorhanden ist
aber nicht zu uns neues bio das war
falsch es ist schon so dass in
bergtourismus tendenz eher stagnierend
ist dass sie sich nicht so dass mir das
ja ne vas beispiel zu nennen nimmt
tendenziell sogar eher leicht ab also
macht mehr sinn wenn wir qualität
investieren anstatt die quantität
das gilt auch für den skc selber
[Musik]
oberhalb von zinal im wallis auf 3200
metern steht die neueste ehc bitte die
gabel truck
der neubau wurde diesen sommer eröffnet
als ersatz für eine alte hütte seit über
30 jahren hat der sc keinen neuen hütten
mehr gebaut sondern nur alte renoviert
oder ersetzt wie rufus und die hütten
kommission des sc starten dem 5
millionen bau einen ersten besuch ab
[Applaus]
hellere und kleinere schlafräume der
erste eindruck ist positiv
auch für den sap chef
große fenster und was man jetzt ganz
speziell gefertigt
das ist schon das ist zukunft
das war die alte hütte 100 jahre alt
kalt feucht ungemütlich
komfortable hütten ziehen neue gäste an
kein widerspruch zum naturschutzgedanken
des clubs ich glaube es ist gut dass die
berg und entdecken und es nicht so wenn
oberstufe die ihr verkehrt ich hatte
aber nie vor der ganze berg berghotel
und so weiter und so fort
luxus ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die küche fast wie in einem hotel
die fünfköpfige küchencrew unter hütten
chefin am limes sorgt auch für ein gutes
menü
[Musik]
wir versuchen immer frisches gemüse zu
servieren
auch finden ist das nicht so die regel
aber wir finden das richtig und es wird
geschätzt
wir wollen schließlich dass es den
leuten bei uns gefällt
[Musik]
eine hütte mit aussicht liga bande trakt
ist einer der größten des sc mit 120
plätzen und 6000 übernachtungen jährlich
und hat das konservative geister im
aufruhr bringt wir schauen jetzt die
sanitären anlagen und die dusche
eigentlich haben wir hier sogar zwei
duschen ich zeige sie die das sind die
waschbecken
wir haben eine dusche für die frauen
auf der anderen seite ist die der männer
es gibt eine zeitschalter zwei minuten
kosten 15 franken wir waren uns bewusst
dass das teuer ist das nicht viele leute
duschen werden aber eine dusche oberhalb
von 3000 meter ist für mich luxus
besichtigungstermin für die shc
mitglieder der bauherr erklärt die
technik eine berghütte ökologisch zu
bauen ist schwierig vor allem die wc
anlage ist hoch oben am berg eine
bauliche herausforderung das wild
funktioniert oder was wir dringend
verkaufen und urin seien feststoffe
fallen auf ein laufband das treibt der
nutzer indem er ein pedal beträgt die
feststoffe sollten dann in große säcke
in einem raum im untergeschoss der hit
landet der menschliche abfall
alles wird ende saison eingetrocknet und
per helikopter ins tal transportiert
die problematik ein problem das wir noch
lösen müssen ist dass viele papier das
die alpinisten benutzen auch die
energieversorgung ist moderne
solarzellen an der fassade produzieren
windstrom die solarenergie wird in
batterien gespeichert
zur unterstützung steht aber auch hier
ein diesel-generator bereit
energie experte jörg nipkow der ehc biel
hütten möglichst nachhaltig betreiben
obwohl die ansprüche steigen
aber das geld irgendwie bis dies
schlafplatz sowieso und da sie stellen
das sind ein jogger wanderer reklamieren
machen setzt erfahrung das war andere
künstler mit der selbst bücher als sehr
gut und comfortline jetzt wo sind dann
die dusche sind endlich und sie
den trend der zeit kann sich auch der
ehc nicht verschließen
auch wenn der spagat zwischen natur
schützen und die berge nutzen immer
größer wird
[Musik]
in der fremden hütte riecht andrea lüthi
am frühen morgen mit ihren sap kollegen
zur bergtour zum freund norn auf zuerst
geht es angeseilt über den fremden
gletscher wie an vielen orten erleben
die bergsteiger hier den
gletscherschwund die eisdecke ist in den
letzten jahren massiv kleinere worden
in der länge vor allem aber auch in der
dicke das hat einfluss aufs per gps
waren noch andere zeiten als fritz 1871
als erster hier oben war auf dem fremden
horn auf 3300 meter das ziel der sap
gruppe
[Musik]
unten in der fremden hütte alle
bergsteiger sind ausgeflogen
mag der hüttenwart hat eine entscheidung
getroffen
seit sechs jahren ist er hier oben jetzt
will er schweren herzens den job als
hüttenwart aufgeben
er sitzt dann die nordbremer jetzt
neuerdings vortritt und etwas glück
freut sich noch so jetzt bin in einem
alter das noch machen wenn jetzt noch
zwei jahre jung geblieben es wird immer
durch wenige noch irgendwie drin steht
und das ist auch gut so
und der zweite grund ihrer arbeit juli
hobbys von yoga machen welchen flügen
werkstücke und über jedes schöne
wochenend und jeden tag bin ich einfach
abziehen
trotzdem ist für ihn jetzt schon klar
dass ihm die schönheit der berge fehlen
wird
ja ja total
[Musik]
eisen tritte und kabel erleichtern der s
t gruppe am fremden horn den aufstieg
mag der hüttenwart hat sie bisher
unterhalten
[Applaus]
4 andrea lüthi und ihre sap gruppe ist
nochmals konzentration angesagt sie
dürfen keinen fehler machen
andreas seil führerin kann mit der
verantwortung gut umgehen
wie mag der hüttenwart hat sie die berge
im blut seit ihrer kindheit dass sie mit
mir selbst auch nicht gedacht hätte
[Musik]
die natur genießen und ein ziel
erreichen das ist es was heute die
menschen in die berge zieht und was
heute noch den reiz des skc ausmacht
[Musik]
wie wichtig die berge den modernen
menschen einmal werden könnten
das hätten sich die alpen pioniere vor
150 jahren wohl noch nicht ausgemalt
[Musik]